اذهب الى مين درغامي وهو معنا من بلده
كوجين كينو في مقاطعه
امينه يرحب بك انت في عين المكان اذا كيف
هي متابعتك لما يجري هنا
سفيان نعم نحن في هذه البلده التي في
منطقه غير بعيده عنها تبعد بنحو كيلومترين
فقط من هذا المكان حيث اقف تحطمت تلك
الطائر الطائره التي يعتقد ان
قائد مجموعه العسكريه الروسيه قد قتل فيها
هذه المنطقه وصلنا اليها قبل قليل هي
منطقه مغلقه ومطوقه بشكل كامل من قبل
اجهزه الامن الروسيه بمختلف تشكيلاتها
وتخصصاتها التحقيقات بوشرت في مكان الحادث
بعد انتشال ضحايا من هذه الطائره العشره
الذي اعلن عنهم او العثور على بقاياهم في
وقت سابق مرت قبل قليل سياره كبيره من هنا
من جاءت من تلك المنطقه التي اتحطمت في
الطائره وكانت فيها الصناديق وعلب كبيره
يعتقد انها تحمل بعض المتعلقات التي عثر
عليها في مكان سقوط الطائره الذي اذا
راينا خلفي هناك ضوء في الافق يظهر خلف
الشاشه وهو المكان الذي تعمل فيه الان
اجهزه الامن وايضا المحققين الروس في
ملابسات تحطم هذه الطائره مصادر طبعا من
شركه فارغنر او مصدر سياسي بالاحرى اكد
للجزيره على ان بريجورن قتل في هذه
الحادثه او في سقوط هذه الطائره لكن طبعا
حتى الان السلطات الروسيه لم تعلن عن اي
تاكيد يمكن ان يضع
مساله مقتل يفكيني برغوجين في هذه الحادثه
بشكل مؤكد ورسمي
ولربما الساعات المقبله ستظهر
ربما مزيد من التفاصيل فيما يتعلق
بما جرى لربما ستكون هناك تصريحات للجنه
التحقيق الروسيه التي باشرت كما سبق وقلت
تحقيقاتها في عين المكان لكن حتى الان
يمنع ليس فقط على الصحفيين بل كما قيل لنا
هنا سفيان حتى على بعض اجهزه الامن الوصول
الى ذلك المكان الذي تحطمت فيه الطائره
الخاصه
اجراءات امنيه مشدده على طول الطريق
الرابط بين
الاستراد الرئيسيه الرابط بين موسكو وسام
بيترسبورغ وايضا الطريق الفرعيه المؤديه
الى هذه البلده التي تحولت خلال ساعات
قليله فقط سفيان الى محطه اندار العالم
بسبب طبعا ما جرى وسائل اعلام روسيه
واجنبيه تتقاطر على هذه المنطقه لكن
المنطقه مغلقه بشكل كامل يمنع يمنع على
الاطقم الصحفيه
الوصول اليها وطبعا يعتقد انه غدا على
الارجح سيتم الاعلان عما تم العثور عليه
حتى الان الحديث عن بعض المتعلقات التي
عثر عليها من بينها الهاتف الشخصي
حتى الان لا توجد اي معلومات عن مصير
الصندوقين الاسودين لهذه الطائره وكل
الفرضيات الان باتت تقريبا شبه مؤكد مقتل
طبعا في انتظار اي تصريح رسمي يضع هذه
الفرضيه بنسبه مئه بالمئه وبالتالي يتاكد
مقتل قائد مجموعه فاجنر يمكن ايضا الحديث
عن مسار هذه الرحله هذه المنطقه في
الحقيقه تقع على النقطه او على منتصف
الطريق بين موسكو
بما يعني ان الطائره تحطمت وسقطت بعد نحو
30 دقيقه فقط من اقلاعها من مطار
شيريميتيفا في شمال موسكو باتجاه
كان قد وصل اليوم فقط من احدى الدول
الافريقيه كما اكد على ذلك مصدر في شركه
فاجنر واقام
باستراحه لربما وجيزه في موسكو قبل
استقلال طائره اخرى من اجل الذهاب الى
حيث مقر اعماله حيث مقر شركه فاجنر وحيث
ايضا بعض الشركات التابعه له والاعمال
طبعا كانت هناك انباء عن الطائره الثانيه
ايضا التابعه او المملوكه لمؤسس شركه
فاجنر ايفغيني كانت قد حطت بعد نحو ساعتين
او ثلاثه في احد المطارات الخاصه في جنوب
مو لم يتاكد وجود وما هو مؤكد مكانه طبعا
هيئه الطيران الفيدراليه الروسيه قد اعلنت
عنه منذ الساعات الاولى لتحطم هذه الطائره
وهو وجود اسم
وعدد من قاده شركه
فعليا وعدد من نوابه وطبعا اضافه الى طاقم
هذه الطائره المكون من ثلاثه اشخاص طبعا
توجد هناك فرضيات بطبيعه الحال
طرحت حتى الان من بينها لربما تعرض هذه
الطائره الى شيء ما عندما نقول شيئا ما
فربما هنا الفرضيه فرضيه العمل التخريبي
موجوده فرديه ارتطام هذه الطائره بجسم او
بشيء ما في الاجواء لربما هذا ايضا محتمل
وهذه هي
الدراسات التي كنت فقط قبل قليل قد تحدثت
عنها
تدخل وتخرج من تلك المنطقه التي تحطمت
فيها الطائره تنقل بعض
المتعلقات وبعض الاشياء التي تم العثور
عليها في موقع تحطم هذه الطائره التحقيقات
بوشرت وهي ما زالت متواصله بشان هذه
النقطه امين اولا يعني قبل لجنه تحقيق
لماذا يصعب يعني في اطار التحقيقات
الجاريه لماذا يصعب التعرف على هويات هذه
الجثث وتاكيدها من جهه جهه اخرى لماذا
تتاخر ايضا التصريحات الرسميه بشان ما حصل
هل من قراءه في الامرين
ربما هناك تريس
سفيان فيما يتعلق بالافصاح عن نتائج هذه
التحقيقات تم بالفعل التعرف على بعض الجثث
في موقع تحطم هذه الطائره ولم يعلن عن
هويات او الاشخاص العشره بشكل كامل
القائمه الكامله للركاب هذه الطائره لربما
الموضوع لحساسيته من جهه
للشخصيات التي كانت تقل هذه التي كانت
تركب في هذه الطائره من جهه ثانيه ولربما
ينتظر الانتهاء اولا من مسح مكان تحطم هذه
الطائره لربما العثور على
الصندوقين الاسودين
اجراء بعض الفحوصات المتعلقه بالحمض
النووي لجثره اخرى لربما قد
تضررت او يعني اصيبت بتشوهات كبيره يصعب
على المحققين في مكان تحطم هذه الطائره
التعرف عليهم بشكل مباشر بالرغم من ان كل
ما صدر حتى الان سفيان يذهب في اتجاه ان
من بين ركاب هذه الطائره التي تحطمت
ومؤسس شركه فاجنر العسكريه اضافه الى
نائبه وكانت ايضا في وقت سابق هناك
معلومات تتحدث عن ان ما يعرف بمجلس قاده
شركه فاجنر العسكريه وهم القاده
الميدانيين بالدرجه الاولى سواء في
بيلاروسيا او في بعض الدول الافريقيه
كانوا يعتزمون عقد اجتماع موسع بينهم وبعد
ذلك الادلاء بتصريح مصور حتى الان لم يصدر
هذا التصريح لربما هناك تريث من كل
الاطراف سواء السلطات الروسيه تنتظر لربما
انتهاء هذه التحقيقات وبعد ذلك الاعلان
بشكل كامل ومفصل عن ما جرى عن هويات الق
عن الاسباب التي ادت وهذا لربما الامر
الاكثر اهميه فيما جرى الاسباب التي ادت
الى تحطم هذه الطائره خاصه وان شهود عيان
ونقلا طبعا عن وسائل اعلام روسيه كانت قد
تحدثت عن سماع دوي انفجار لحظات فقط قبل
سقوط وتحطم هذه الطائره ما يرجح اذا
اضفناها طبعا سفيان الى الصور التي تم
تناقلها صور الاولى او اللحظات والثواني
الاولى
لسقوط هذه الطائره كان يبدو بشكل واضح
تصاعد الدخان من الطائره وهي تهوي وكانها
اصطدمت بشيء ما او اصيبت
بصاروخ لربما بطائره مسيره او لربما تعرضت
الى تفجير من داخل الطائره وهنا طبعا نفتح
قوسين
والفرديه فرضيه العمل التخريبي مطروحه
ايضا لكن حتى الان ينتظر ان تنتهي
التحقيقات من اجل الاعلان الرسمي من قبل
لجنه التحقيقات الفيدراليه الروسيه عن
الاسباب عن الحيثيات وايضا عن
ركاب هذه الطائره
وقائمه من كان على متنها بشكل كامل سفي